there have been stories that some of the
pro Corbin MPs did decided not to vote
in that election but have to say it's a
quite a high turnout that they managed
to get despite that so 95 percent
turnout among MPs which is very high
overwhelming number of MPs they're
deciding that they don't back Jeremy
Corbyn 172 against him okay let's go
back to fires also fires all 80 percent
my goodness me where does that leave
Jeremy Corbyn he rallied the troops last
nine he came outside Parliament he spoke
to those that had gathered many
thousands outside and he said I'm
staying
he certainly still represents quite a
lot of the grassroots but we can see
here is not representing a lot of the
MPs in Parliament so you have a
constitutional schism within Labour
Party because on the one hand it's clear
the party leader is elected by the
membership and then becomes the leader
of the parliamentary Labour Party
whether they like it or not many were
Milly are willing to make it work over
the past nine to ten months and now they
feel it hasn't worked and that the
situation that the country arrives in
post the brexit referendum is just far
too serious for what they saw as an
experiment to continue jeremy corbyn's
response to that is I gained my mandate
from the members not from the
parliamentary Labour Party if you've got
an issue stand in a leadership election
and we'll bring it back to the
membership to the calculation of the PLP
is if the membership can ever be
detached from their love for Jeremy
Corbyn it will be in these circumstances
circumstances where Britain has walked
out of the European Union in a
referendum and where we face the
possibility of a general election where
the Labour Party would have to put up a
candidate currently that would be Jeremy
Corbyn against most likely Boris Johnson
in those circumstances the parliamentary
Labour Party feel that they might be
able to detach the membership away from
Jeremy Corbyn and they feel that they've
got evidence for that from a welter of
letters and emails and messages in the
aftermath of the EU referendum that is
the key dynamic nobody knows whether
it's actually fired nobody knows whether
the membership has actually changed but
that is the calculation k we may just be
about to find out